during yesterday's White House Press
briefing Ed O'Keefe asked spokeswoman
Kareem Jean-Pierre why the discovery of
the documents at Mr Biden's house was
not revealed sooner
first set of documents were found in
November at the Penn Biden Center here
in Washington but why did it take until
yesterday and until this morning
apparently for whoever it was to inform
Robert lausch that that final document
was found was that because there were
press reports earlier this week again
and the Hope was that nobody would find
out again it wasn't because there is a
process an ongoing process that is
occurring we did this by the book and
what I mean by that is the moment that
the lawyers discovered that the papers
were there or the documents were there
they reached out to the archives they
reach out to Department of Justice
and Ed O'Keefe joins us now we didn't
get to see that uh sound bite in its
entirety yet but I certainly I was
watching from my kitchen sitting at the
table there was definitely frustration
from the White House Press Corps
certainly frustration on the part of
Kareem Jean-Pierre and she kept
repeating over and over about
transparency what did you make of her
responses
there's different kinds of transparency
at work here Gail there's the legal
transparency that they say they are
doing and come and and you know working
with the archives working with the
justice department and going by the book
lawyer to lawyer investigator to subject
what they're not being is publicly
transparent or straight with the
American people about what happened here
there was nothing stopping the president
of the United States from disclosing to
the public that this had happened back
in November but as we pointed out it
happened just a few days before the
election was that it is part of the
reason why they opted not to disclose
this that's one of the unanswered
questions there was nothing stopping him
in December from disclosing it when the
second batch was founded as Wilmington
home why didn't he decide to disclose it
then it's another unanswered question
and they have decided for now here at
the White House to be legally
transparent with the justice department
but not be straight with the American
people and answer all the questions in
hopes that the legal matter can be dealt
with quickly and that they can move on
and the court of public opinion Ed as we
know can get very loud and doesn't go
away so how do you see this playing out
politically I'm still so confused about
how boxes Matt Mark classified leave the
White House at all right how do you see
this playing out well there's the
ongoing Justice Department investigation
that will now be led by a special
prosecutor who had worked during the
Trump Administration hired in part to
assuage any concerns that this is uh
that there's political favoritism but
they're going to be investigations held
by Republicans who now run the House of
Representatives and various committees
will be asking questions so there will
be a legal fight for the president and
there will be a political mess on
Capitol Hill and in the meantime
unanswered questions that we will
continue trying to get answers to
regarding what did he know when did he
know it and if not who did
all right Ed thank you because right now
both sides are going like this pointing
at the other guy and so it continues
thank you very much